[Musique]
cela fait près d'un siècles que de
poulet rôti fait le bonheur des petits
idées grands au Québec pourquoi on aime
tant le poulet rôti au Québec est-ce
qu'il y a une explication derrière ça je
pense parce que très tôt il y a 100 ans
on avait déjà des restaurants de poulet
rôti les pionniers et les côtes barbecue
les Laury barbecue qui était là dans les
années 30 je pense c'était ils ont un
cul qui est ça dans la culture
québécoise c'était accessible c'était
facile c'était bon c'est abordable c'est
facile à amener à maison face à manger
sur place donc je pense que ça répondait
beaucoup de besoins de la population
et pour répondre à ce besoin ça prend
beaucoup de poulet un poulet
rôti avec on achète au-delà de 3
millions pour le travail
le poulet et la viande la plus consommée
au pays un Canadien mange en moyenne
34,4 kg de poulet par an et qui dit
popularité dit compétitions
c'est une bonne compétition ça nous
permet de devenir meilleur puis un
meilleur risque toujours lorsqu'on a au
client face à une telle compétition pas
le choix d'innover on innover une
version périphérie une version indienne
très populaire mais sont loin de la
popularité du poulet rôti barbecue qu'on
connaît 45% de notre bonus c'est du
poulet rôti
nous avons voulu savoir si la populaire
poitrine de poulet variait d'une
rôtisserie à l'autre
c'est la commande nous en avons donc
commandé chez les 4 principales
rôtisseries Saint-Hubert Beni & Co au
coq escort merci beaucoup parfait bonne
journée
premier constat pas de grosses
différences dans les prix de livraison
mais c'est tout de même scores qui offre
le repas le plus cher à 18 dollars 95
en est-il de même pour le poids nous
avons vérifié
297 on a l'impression à l'oeil qui en a
plus du côté de Saint-Hubert après avoir
vérifié chacun est pesé chacun des items
c'est nettement plus généreux comme
portion
et selon notre questionnaire maison
effectué sur nos réseaux sociaux le
poulet de chez Benny et le préféré de
nos 200 répondeurs et les rôtisseries ne
sont pas les seuls à se faire
compétition des supermarchés deviennent
compétiteur très important eux aussi
vendre du poulet rôti et aussi on des
solutions de repas prémangiées
les plus vendus en épicerie ça reste un
produit économique c'est un produit
simple facile à préparer pour les
familles un produit qui n'a jamais été
aussi bon marché en 2011 l'épicerie
avait déjà comparé l'offre des poulets
rôtis question prix pour vous délecter
de poulet rôti vous paierez plus cher au
kilo en rôtisserie et en épicerie autour
de 15 dollars en rôtisserie et 10
dollars en épicerie
11 ans plus tard le poulet le moins cher
se vend moins de 7 dollars le kilo chez
Costco et le plus cher est chez Métro où
il vous en coûtera plus de doubles alors
comment les épiceries arrivent-elles à
offrir un prix aussi avantageux
très très important au niveau du
consommateur donc c'est un produit pour
nous que c'est un produit d'appel on
cherche est très très compétitif sur ce
produit un produit d'appel est un
produit sur lequel les épiceries ne font
pas ou très peu de profit mais qui
permet d'attirer la clientèle en magasin
est-ce que ce sont des poulets proche de
la table de péremption que vous faites
cuire dans vos cuisines avec la réponse
est non c'est des livraisons uniquement
pour le poulet
à pâtisserie donc c'est pas du poulet
qui sont déjà en magasin ce sont des
poulets qui sont calibrés donc il y a un
poids moyen un poids minimum un poids
maximum au niveau de chaque poulet une
question plus tabou du côté des
rôtisserie c'est quoi la grosseur du
poulet qu'on va avoir chez St-Hubert
on dit pas
est-ce qu'on se prie occupe des valeurs
nutritionnelles quand on achète un
poulet rôti à l'exception des petits
diables et un petit peu de sodium qu'on
va retrouver du poulet ça reste une
protéine qui est très maigre donc une
très bonne côté à consommer pour la
famille
de sodium très maigre pour le savoir
nous avons fait analyser en laboratoire
cinq poulets rôties d'épicerie nous
analyses révèlent que le poulet rôti est
moins salé que ce que les grandes
chaînes allègent sur leurs étiquettes le
poulet de Costco est d'ailleurs le plus
salé de notre échantillon il arrive
néané avec celui de IgA quant au goût
des répondants de notre questionnaire
maison par contre le poulet est
relativement gras si vous mangez un
quart de poulet de Walmart et Costco
vous atteindrez le tiers de la valeur
quotidienne recommandée en gras et
jusqu'à la moitié pour ceux de IgA et
Provigo sans compter des frites la sauce
le pain et la salade de chou
oh ça sent bon
on dirait que chez ma grand-mère un
dimanche soir ici l'envie vous prend de
faire votre poulet rôti maison voici
quelques conseils du chef Martin
leduca poivre
gousse d'ail ce qu'on veut savoir
l'odeur de l'ail à travers notre poulet
du romarin du pain frais
un parti le fun maintenant c'est de
mettre le beurre en dessous de la peau
on va le porter on a besoin de la peau
pour garder le beurre dans la bête on
est rendu à l'étape de ficeler le poulet
on va garder l'humidité à l'intérieur et
le poulet va pas sortir ça peut être
n'importe quel légume moi je prends des
pommes de terre
donc on prend notre contenant
d'aluminium on vient déposer nos pommes
de terre dans le fond le but c'est de
faire un lit pour soulever le poulet
on va venir hydrater notre poulet avec
un jus ça peut être un bouillon de
poulet ça peut être de l'eau notre
alcool préféré l'équivalent de peut-être
un litre de liquide pas plus haut que
les pommes de terre on fait cuire au
four à 350 degrés pendant plus de deux
heures en prenant soin d'arroser toutes
les 20 minutes
puis après est-ce que je peux garder les
autres puis me faire un bouillon oui
facilement une trentaine de minutes dans
l'eau les eaux la peau cartilage ça fait
un beau bouillon bien coloré et
appétissant et pas de gaspillage on peut
même récupérer le jus de cuisson on
vient de l'épaisseur avec un peu de
fécule de maïs puis notre sauce est
prête